Although the reviews of this year's Suicide
Squad movie have been mixed at best, there
were some aspects of the movie that were almost
universally praised.
One of those was Margot Robbie's Harley Quinn.The
Aussie actress excelled in the role of the
Joker's insane but strangely likeable girlfriend
- and she looked gorgeous in the process.
It's no surprise, therefore, that Warner Brothers
and DC have already made plans for a spin-off
solo movie for the character.
That made us think about what we'd like to
see going on in that movie - and that's what
this video is all about.
Here are 10 things we need in the Harley Quinn
solo movie.
More About Her Origins
Suicide Squad certainly touched upon Harley
Quinn's origins - she was working at Arkham
Asylum as the Joker's psychiatrist, fell in
love with him, and was ultimately driven insane
by him - but they're so interesting that we'd
really like to see them explored in a deeper
manner in her solo movie.It doesn't need to
be an origin movie - that would mean setting
it in the past, and we'd really like to see
the DCEU progressing chronologically - but
seeing how Dr. Harleen Quinzel turned into
Harley Quinn in a little more detail would
undoubtedly be interesting.
Her Classic Costume
In the Suicide Squad movie, Harley Quinn did
wear a costume reminiscent of the more recent
comic books in which she has appeared, but
fans of the character would really like to
see her wearing her more iconic and classic
jester costume on screen.It was briefly shown
in the movie - in the scene when the members
of the titular team were choosing their accessories
for their mission - but Margot Robbie's character
didn't wear it.
However, the fact that it has been shown to
exist in the DCEU means we're really expecting
her to don it at some point - and her solo
movie is the most obvious platform of opportunity
to make that happen.
Her Classic Weapon
Like her costume in the movie, Suicide Squad
didn't depict Harley Quinn with her most iconic
weapon.
She mainly used a baseball bat - something
she has used in the comic books - but we'd
really like to see her wielding her classic
giant mallet.It was shown on screen - in the
same scene that her classic jester costume
was shown, when she was choosing her accessories
for the mission - but she didn't use it at
all.
In her solo movie, it would be great to see
her beating the hell out of her opponents
with her most recognisable weapon from the
comic books.
An R-Rating
Suicide Squad was rated PG-13 and - in spite
of the fact that it was nowhere near as bad
as some critics would have you believe - it
definitely suffered from it.
A PG-13 rating is something that the Harley
Quinn solo movie should definitely stay away
from.It should be rated R, like Deadpool was
- because, if that movie proved anything,
it's that rated R comic book movies can be
awesome.
Due to Harley's very nature, her movie would
benefit greatly from it, as it could push
the boundaries in terms of its violence, its
craziness and its humour - three things that
the character is absolutely all about.
The Joker
Harley Quinn's movie should definitely focus
mainly on her - and it could be argued that
bringing in other characters with huge personalities
could be detrimental to its charm - but there's
no way a Harley Quinn movie should ever be
made without an appearance from The Joker.Not
only is the Clown Prince of Gotham synonymous
with Harley, but we also didn't see anywhere
near enough of Jared Leto's version of the
character in Suicide Squad - and any opportunity
to see more of what that version is all about
would be welcomed by most fans (and by Jared
Leto himself, of course).
Barbara Gordon
We're yet to see a comic book movie in which
both the protagonist and antagonist are female
- which is absolutely crazy when you think
about it - but the Harley Quinn solo movie
could very easily rectify that by having Barbara
Gordon going up against the most unpredictable
member of the Suicide Squad.Whether it was
in her Batgirl guise or her Oracle guise - both
of which would make for very interesting dynamics
in the movie - it would be awesome and extremely
refreshing for the comic book movie genre
to see a Quinn versus Gordon face-off in live
action.
Batman
Having just stated that Barbara Gordon should
be the hero going up against Harley Quinn
in the latter's solo movie, you're probably
wondering what Batman is doing on this list.
But, come on man, you can't have a Harley
movie without the character who enabled her
to exist in the first place.Harley was introduced
in Batman: The Animated Series and has lived
in his world ever since.
Their relationship is an interesting one.
Although they're classically foes, there's
clearly sexual tension between the pair and
that would be interesting to see explored.
Moreover, getting to see Ben Affleck's Batman
on screen again should be okay in everybody's
book - he's awesome.
Poison Ivy
As of June 2015, a new lover stepped into
Harley Quinn's life on the page of DC Comics
- none other than the sexy and sultry Batman
villain known as Poison Ivy.
And wouldn't that be cool to explore in live
action on the big screen?!After the pair first
got together, DC's Twitter account officially
announced the relationship by saying that
the pair were "girlfriends without the jealousy
of monogamy".
And, let's face it, very few people (especially
of the male variety) would complain about
seeing Margot Robbie getting down with another
beautiful actress.
Some Group Banter
In the Suicide Squad movie, Margot Robbie's
Harley Quinn absolutely thrived when surrounded
by the rest of her titular team - especially
Will Smith's Deadshot.
With that in mind, it would be cool to see
her - at least briefly - interacting with
a large group of characters in her solo movie.Whether
she pays a visit to her former prison buddies
and team mates, or whether she ends the movie
as part of another group such as the Birds
of Prey or Gotham City Sirens, Harley needs
an audience to play up to in order to be at
her best.
Hopefully she'll get that opportunity, in
spite of the inherent nature of a solo movie
- in fact, DC and Warner Brothers have actually
stated that there will be a large cast of
supporting characters already, so this is
a distinct possibility.
Easter Eggs & References Galore
Harley Quinn is such an interesting and wacky
character with such a rich history - albeit
a brief one in comic book terms - that all
kinds of awesome Easter eggs and references
could be included in her solo movie.
That's exactly what we want to see happen.For
instance, a reference to Batman: The Animated
Series - the show in which the character first
appeared - would be very cool to see, as would
links and references to other characters she
has associated with in various ways, like
Power Girl, Holly Robinson, Nightwing and
the Ventriloquist.
Essentially, Harley's movie could be used
to potentially expand the DCEU in many different
ways, with some of the quirkiest Easter eggs
in comic book movie history.
Thanks for watching our video of 10 things
we need in the Harley Quinn solo movie.
Did you enjoy this video?
What else do you want to see in Harley's solo
outing?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.